the other thing that links are about
just everyone started very young now ben
the last time you're here
we enjoyed very much uh your early work
on the voyage of the mimi yes we're not
gonna show any more thank you do google
it because it is worth seeing
[Laughter]
tell me more
no seriously you really need to google
it
sienna you started was it modeling you
started you were quite young when you
started modeling i was just sure and so
i no i mean yes but not like proper
[Applause]
and then emma you did some extraordinary
work as a child actor
i mean take this meryl streep oh
i did a kind of edgar g robinson thing
where i was like
in mind we are going to focus on the
early dancing career of mr ryan gosling
make sense um the only video you have
tonight is yeah yeah is this so the
dance troupe you were in can you tell us
about because apparently
young dancers they could be quite
vicious
it's a cutthroat business
and i had to get out
i i was on some
kind of uh canadian star search and uh i
somehow made it to the finals and uh my
main competition were these two
uh twins who were tap dancers and they
were dancing to phil collins uh two
hearts
and they had big heart-shaped bows and
they were just uh
they were the ones to beat so
i remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and i was getting
ready to start was dancing the everybody
dance now by cnc music factory of course
yeah and i'm getting ready to start
which is this is how you started a
winning dance number if you want to know
get out of your hand tonight
just off stage and the two twins are
standing there like the
twins from the shining
and they're just going like this
[Applause]
to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
because i i was good is this the same
dream i was going to say it's an all
it's an all-girl troupe but obviously
it's not you're in it right but but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the was that the that was the point that
was the gimmick they let me dance there
for free because i was a guy because if
you
had a guy you you would win
oh okay yeah so are you ready to see the
the
dance silence
i believe you're dancing to kathy
dennis's classic touch me
um uh did the troupe have a name ryan
it was elite dance studio
uh and how old are you in this one
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
i wish i could say someone said here you
have to wear this
but that was my idea i thought i have a
vision for this number
pikeball and silver hammer pants
they are br the silver hammer plants are
i don't think we know we gave them
enough of a shot we gave up with hammer
but i don't i think we should we should
have kept them going
no yeah
i'm talking about your effort to do well
in was it an exam about statistics oh
god christ yes this is true i i got a d
in that yeah you got a d i got a d but
but but
i mean i i deserve that or or worse but
anyway so so you're in school you're
doing an exam statistics your teacher
she's miss lauten
yes latin lawton lot miss lawton and so
what were the other kids doing were the
other kids just doing
uh yeah variation i mean i mean
some people presented parabolas and
things that were
more appropriate for statistics uh you
know varied projects mine was not so
tell the people what you decided to do
like a statistics song
yes sort of a sort of statistics ramp
yeah horrible bad bad level the worst
level yes but no you came up with the
whole rap persona didn't you yeah but
not for that i just had it oh
so lil is it little timmy tim yeah it's
part of my uh
oh you're gonna regret it
gingerbread man is nothing now
how do we have this film did you post it
how did how does this film make sure i
posted it i did it with a friend on a
green screen in school and i'm pointing
to different i was going to photoshop my
teacher's face in but i got too lazy so
now they're just kind of weird in the
video i'm pointing around and there's
there's nothing
well here are these statistical
rap stylings of little timmy tips
look at me it's timmy t
hit him
[Music]
[Applause]
i did not know this about you i don't
know you do you play tomb raider at all
don't be ridiculous no no i thought you
might no but i like the girl in it um
lara croft yeah the shorts now have you
played tomb raider
merrell what tomb raider i don't even
know what you're talking about okay
well at least laura knows the girl
longer well
shut your eyes you grant because the
voice of lara croft is sitting beside
you oh look what yeah well that's not
that's that's the voice of the game
yes
the voice of larkov is kelly was now
apparently this got confusing for your
son is this true it did it did when i
first started doing it my son who will
kill me um after this
my son who's now 15 but was was quite
little and
uh he could never get past the first
stage and so he you just make her run
around and sort of swim and rock climb
and things but um she has she wears
these shorts you know um and uh so he's
doing that and then he came running and
he said mommy i said how's it going you
know you're enjoying
he said
i like the way the lady runs
the lady with my with mommy's voice was
a bit
did you then ban him from playing that
thing yes you did
i've spoken to people who've done this
and it's not as simple you don't just
say the lines i mean it takes
hours and hours doesn't it
because don't you have to make every
little noise that you might ever
conceivably make yeah well let me say a
a person let's call them a fan has put
together seriously has put together
every noise you make
not every noise
[Laughter]
i i i bet you differ
i think we are about to hear every noise
you make
it takes a little while you can shut
your eyes you'll enjoy this
this is uh the vocal stylings of philly
halls as lara croft
oh god
someone has taken the time to put this
together
that's a falling off a cliff death
it's a really long one in a second
[Laughter]
she's done
last year last march or april i mean so
it's been a year yeah so you must be
nearly finished because i broke my ankle
we had to shut down but we're about six
weeks away the ankle this is that so are
you fully recovered are you well it's
still broken but i'm doing well no
you're kidding is it still broken yeah i
mean it's not fully healed but we're
shooting but that's nuts because we've
seen no we've seen a picture of you
you're running and doing all stuff again
yeah now but we have a release date so
we got to keep going yeah otherwise
you'll end up going live yes
it's much better
so
you probably i'm sure you all saw the
the footage in in it was on the papers
and things on online of the accident yes
and i think we all kind of thought well
how did you break an ankle doing that
does it look like you should have broken
your jaw or something i know everyone
said that was the stunt i mean i'm gonna
run across and hit the side of the wall
and then pull myself over that wasn't
the mistake
so you're always meant to not yes land
on the roof
okay so what you've done is you brought
us some footage i think this is so cool
to see this from the different angles
this is what i i can't watch this
i haven't watched it
most of it's fine there's one clip but i
will warn you it's not for the squeamish
growth you'll see i'm wearing two wires
they're basically just safety wires
because i'm i go to full tilt and i'm
sprinting as hard as i can and i hit the
side of the wall and that's the stunt i
hit the side of the wall and then i'm
chasing after henry actually
and uh
all his fault i blame him i hit the side
of the wall and then i i climb up on the
wall and i'm supposed to run past kevin
okay so we've got uh this is the shot
from behind you so this is you see the
the speed and the momentum of the run
and it's in london there we go so it's
keeping the okay so here he goes look at
that whoa and
now it's good noise everybody
but you get my point that you think how
did you break a leg so let's look at it
from the side this is it from the side
no no no no this isn't a bad one this
isn't the bad one rebecca so this is
from the side here we go we shot it with
three cameras okay here he goes and boom
now now we've got our camera which
focuses on the foot now if you are
squeamish
don't
[Applause]
i mean a bone doesn't pop out or
anything but it is an odd angle for
anyone's foot to be here but his foot
should ever have to do this yeah here we
go here we go oh my gosh so he jumps
that speed that momentum here we go
and now watch that watch this
but here here is why here is why tom
cruise gets paid the big bucks okay
because this is it from the front angle
okay so you've just seen what's happened
to his foot now watch this i knew i
broke it instantly so you're down now
anyone else would go well that's over no
up he gets
a pig and he's running
[Applause]
i didn't want to do it again i knew i
knew instantly it was broken and i
i just
run past camera we got the shot it's in
the movie that profile shot both those
shots are in the movie
and henry everybody said when you got up
and ran out of shot oh that's so him
to complete the shot like with your foot
hanging off
i just went i said sorry guys it's
broken you know take me to the hospital
it's broken that's a wrap everyone
everyone crew got on the phone and made
their vacation arrangements i made a
baby
i told you that
[Music]
you